for those who don't know what peer
review is basically you write a paper
you send it off to a journal or
increasingly and this will be part of
the resolution of the rant i hope
increasingly you just submit it to uh to
a server where it's available online
even before peer review but
traditionally take the paper send it off
to a journal the journals editors first
of all consider is that paper worthy for
this journal if it is they send it out
for peer review who do they send it to
you they send it to your peers now the
difficulty is so your peers mean people
in the field hopefully experts in your
field hopefully people who you would
think could do a very good job at i'm
looking through your paper criticizing
it critiquing it coming back with
generally i must admit in my case
generally constructive criticism there
are very few cases i can point to um
where a paper anarchist hasn't been
improved by peer review and of course
you get angry and you go oh what this
reviewer news knows nothing but actually
when in the cold light of day which is
difficult for me and one of the reasons
i don't have a twitter account um in the
cold light of day when you stand back
you realize actually they may have a
point here so let's think about doing
this so peer review in that sense that's
the good things about peer review so
this entire process is anonymous
the traditional peer-review process in
our arms so often yes there is the very
strong possibility that when your paper
goes out that it goes to somebody you
know and most times people keep that
information confidential but certainly
sometimes i've had people come up to me
and go well i reviewed your
your paper some time ago
that's an interesting sociological um
quandary to be in because obviously if
so if you get a favorable review from
somebody and they've told you they've
given you a favorable review you're
almost biased if you get their paper to
review so there's a you know there are
issues there the vast majority of the
time and those are rare occasions the
vast majority of the time is you do the
review and it's entirely anonymous i
know science is very collaborative but
there is an element of competition in it
for some people
do you ever worry that someone's going
to try and noble your paper that's a
very many people worry about that i'm
less concerned about that i must admit
i've certainly not really had any
experience of that in the sort of 120
130 odd papers um but uh
the the journal guidelines when which
the center referees specifically mention
this and you know there are strong
ethical guidelines whether those are
always followed i don't know and
certainly there are some you know
scientists are human
and um some are more human than others
that's the good aspects of peer review
it should work to sift out problems with
the interpretation problems with the
results it should work to improve a
paper the problem is the number of
papers goes up and up and up the number
of scientists go it goes up and up and
the number of journals goes up and up
there's a huge volume of stuff and we
are increasingly getting swamped now i
came across this um
relatively recently but it's from the
middle of last year
this is one of the worst examples of
where peer review has entirely failed so
what are we looking at we're looking at
a transmission electron microscope image
of gold nano rods
so you see these rods
which are about you can see from the
scale bar here 50 or 16 nanometers long
and they've basically been synthesized
in solution and they've been put onto a
surface
and you get these structures forming and
the authors because of course if you
want to get a paper into a high profile
journal you need a snappy title so they
term this or coin the term nano
chopsticks
there's too much nano out there so um
nano chopsticks in this case refers to
well you can see that there's a very
well defined angle
and for me
sort of when i look at that image i go
wow that's that's mad that's really
strange why would why would they do that
why wouldn't you deposit them from
solution and all the different types of
dynamics that goes on to solution and
the drying of the solvent why the hell
would they do that why would you get
these very well-defined angles
and then you zoom in
well we zoom in after the event this was
caught by this this wonderful blog
kembark but was missed by the reviewers
all right do you see anything suspicious
there
brady
i mean i'm not brilliant at photoshop
and neither am i but
for zarquon's sake that is just
taking the um
the excretory fluid isn't it it's beyond
a joke how the hell did that get through
peer review if you get an image like
this this top one
and you see that the first thing you do
is
sorry that's terrible it's it is we
laugh about it but you know this is
hundreds of thousands of pounds of
taxpayers money in many cases going to
fund this type of research and this
damages confidence right across the
board in in science this is not some
very poor quality journal at the bottom
this is one of the top you know the top
ranking journals in the field and you
know you can make the argument well you
know the the referees can't be expected
to to you know to catch everything and
if you're one of those referees i'm
sorry and i i i appreciate that you've
got you know large workloads we all have
large workloads but
but but you sent a paper which is
related to how
um rods interact and form these
structures the first thing you as a
referee the first thing i think anybody
in this field would do would go well
that's really interesting what the
hell's happening on it happening at the
apex and then you'd go looking for high
resolution images and then you'd find
this in the supplementary information
they
what
they overlap they cut it out the
background doesn't look the same you can
see this little nudge here
is you know a feature that's repeated
because they they've used the same image
and just rotated my ten-year-old
daughter said daddy why didn't they cut
it out correctly and here's the really
troublesome aspect here's the really oh
they're on to you
i didn't mean it i take it all back this
is the lawyers
hello